[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance
to control the truth the concepts
of right and wrong
for everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
hey look out the window
welcome to my party guys
[Music]
thank you so much for having us this is
my chance to reconnect with the girls
did mom shoot some pieces this little
bump right here that's you i still miss
her every day
what's that there's something crossing
up the head
keep the girls stay in the car okay just
stay in the car
yeah
okay what's he saying
i've never seen anything like this
multiple attacks
without eating its prey
lies don't do that at least no lion i've
ever seen
[Music]
go back to the calls
breathe slow down
we're in his territory now
it's the law of the jungle
it's the only law that matters
they've got guns shouldn't be out here
i need you to trust me right now
i'm coming back
don't you move
okay
once upon a time in a magical castle
the king's daughter
was locked away in a tower
you made a promise to me
that your daughter
would be my wife
i'm not a piece of property to be traded
but these guys
[Music]
with the wrong princess
i like a girly lace
[Music]
i have to save my family
let's get you ready
it's not exactly ladylike behavior
i'll never stop
until i'm holding it
you're still
beating heart
[Music]
i underestimated you i'm used to that
who are you
[Applause]
i'm the princess
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to godbod
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only for
oh spook too soon
jane
[Music]
the old ex-girlfriend
what's a family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
am i uh sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
he's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
[Music]
you
are not like the other gods that kill
him
because i have something worth fighting
for
[Music]
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually grape
[Music]
blue had a baby that's impossible
hey girl
you look just like your mother
[Music]
genetic power has now been unleashed
we made a terrible mistake
the doomsday clock might be about out of
time
if our world's gonna survive what
matters is what we do now
i can use your expertise
you coming or what
a baby raptor i made a promise we would
bring her home
you made a promise
to a dinosaur yeah what
[Music]
everybody hold on to somebody
that can't be right
what is that biggest carnivore the world
has ever seen
run
see not so bad
[Music]
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car got used your
small inside voice in his son there's a
gun
[Music]
[Music]
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world you get peace back
i think you might be forgetting what you
do for a living
take the gun every job i do somebody
dies i'm not that guy anymore
some conflicts require a
[Music]
gun hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase you said you wanted simple
for your first job back it doesn't get
simpler
dude i don't even know you
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
evan
where's the briefcase oh it's not [ __ ]
[Music]
it was just here
we are right on settle everything that's
ever happened to you this is gonna sting
this let you hear
fate
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you domo arigato
i'm sure you want to talk this out no
particularly
okay
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family
[Music]
he's our fortress
[Music]
so
[Applause]
this suit means something
it's not just protecting your body it's
protecting the universe ready captain
lightyear ready as i'll ever be to
infinity and
my mistake has marooned us on this
strange clinic
i need to make it right
hello buzz i am socks my mission is to
help you and i'm not giving up on my
mission i'm not giving up either great
would you like a frosted snack kick to
celebrate negative was like your mission
log i plan to finally finish the mission
oh you're talking to buzz uh no one
here we go
are we going to crash no
well technically yes
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
what is going on
what i hope you're ready for action
because all we needed was a pilot for
what we have to destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team do you
have munitions training partial so
you're rookies oh boy we'd love to be
rookies
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it
engage your helmet that'll catch it
let's go finish the mission
we're being pursued by a
just a massive robot
we can do anything you're not shouting
my ear oh yep
[Music]
hey what's that noise come on don't
break my cat he's purring he likes it
sucks do you like that i do
huh
why do you want to be a samurai
[Music]
i lived in a bad part of town full of
bad dogs
everybody always picked on me
i thought if i could be a samurai
it would change everything
sounds like you need a mentor perhaps a
once great samurai who has fallen on
hard times and maybe could use some help
himself
but where can i find one
get out of here who even made that it's
you don't believe everything you read
[Music]
sorry hank you have to do something
you're under arrest
you wanted to be a samurai fun isn't it
go get them
get back out there
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it
[Applause]
don't forget to land on your
feet
who knew an evil army could go through
so many beams
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this might take a while
all right tv night with my pro
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock i
[Music]
with other animals this just seems gross
we need gross smelling stuff is one of
the greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working up the kings i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs don't you never feed
us chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
but we're stronger than you think
we'll help you get your dumb on the back
it's deployed canines here what is a k-9
[Music]
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why can't i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squishy bros
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
500 grand for you guys his guys and for
you
i can't do this without a crew i'll see
what i can do
20 minutes that'll be our window
everybody now the bank manager is in on
it whatever cash is in the ball it's all
yours
inside you will find this briefcase
people will be looking for that case and
cops
we do this right and everyone gets their
share
[Music]
it's done boss we got the case
good
i can get you your case that was stolen
from the bank let me see if i get this
straight you steal from me they steal
from you and now you want to steal back
from them so you can give it to me yeah
i saw an opportunity so i took it
that's the difference between people
like you and people like me
where's my goddamn briefcase
what the hell is this [ __ ] just got real
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you ain't never land in that plane
you ain't [ __ ]
you shouldn't even be flying
it's good to know the men you're flying
with
[Music]
see what they're fighting for
what are you fighting for
hoping to find that out
[Music]
try to keep up
[Music]
this is
[Music]
and more up
i can't tell you how many times people
have told me to give up quit
die even
that's why you can't always do what
you're told
if i did
i wouldn't be here
[Music]
[Music]
she's out
so
[Applause]
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any
timeline and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the path
are you in
good evening
[Music]
nobody moves
i need to know everybody's alive and
well
you just have to trust me
charlie built stuck
incoming
we made a deal
you broke it
[Music]
huh
[Music]